starting with my delicious mushroom and
leek pasta
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers one in front two behind
up and down
then add olive oil to a hot frying pan
[Music]
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
[Music]
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down
through the center turn it over
and again into quarters so you've got
all that opening up and then just rinse
the top of that to get rid of any
potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add
all that leek
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now the secret is to get rid of that
water inside the leek
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you just left that really nice intense
flavor
garlic's got nice and crispy now we're
going to add a touch of chicken stock in
there
beautiful
lasagna sheets just going to drop the
sheets
in to the water
lasagna sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken start to reduce down by half
and it's almost delays the bottom of the
pan basically washed all that wonderful
flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the bowl and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now the secret with the pasta is just
taking it out a little early
so you've got that nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center it's ready
turn the sauce down
and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just gonna turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing
sauce finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb it goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now
pan for the bread a little touch of
olive oil
as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve
on a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple they can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you can always
make great tasting food at the drop of a
hat my next tasty dish uses simple and
cheap store covered ingredients with
stunning results and takes minutes to
make
sweet corn fritters and yogurt dip it's
brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweetcorn somewhere so i'm going to show
you how to make the most amazing fritter
first off the mixture
take your flour sieve
really important to sieve the flour that
stops the mixture from having any lumps
in there
just before you get to the end
i want to put
half a teaspoon of baking powder the
baking powder gives the mixture some
lift
in
and just sieve that through
a touch of salt
and pepper
next an egg about four tablespoons of
milk
and give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle
of olive oil in there that helps to
relax the mixture
whisk that in make sure we got rid of
all those lumps
so that i want a nice smooth
almost like a cake mixture okay next
take the seeds out of a chili to lower
the heat roll the chilli so give it a
really good
shake
[Music]
tap them out
slice
in half
into quarter
and each quarter
in half
and chop through
it's a really nice quick way
of slicing a chili
into the mixture spring onion
take off that outside layer of the
spring onion top and tail slice it in an
angle
it's a little bit of texture running
through the mixture i want that nice
crunch
in coriander
just slice through
nice and gently
and get that in there
next to the sweetcorn now drain it from
the tin and just pat it dry so it
doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now i've got two thirds
ingredients and one third of the mixture
to bind together that's the secret of a
good freighter so you're
you're biting into excitement and not
sort of dough
pan on
olive oil in
nice and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion
in
space the fritters evenly around the pan
in a clockwise direction so you always
know which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit okay
palette knife
just check
and happy with the color
and turn over
beautiful
now for the chili yogurt dressing
deseed and finely chop a red chilli
and add to a pot of natural yogurt
and then
some fresh lime
[Music]
finish with chopped coriander
coriander in
and give that
a nice mix up
that chilli just lifts it
the lime gives it that nice tanginess
the fritters
they smell amazing and with the sauce
tastes fantastic
that is such a delicious recipe using a
tin of sweet corn from your cupboard
amazing
beef tacos with wasabi mayo
the great thing about street food is
anything goes the only rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos mix a mexican and
japanese flavors into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off get that pan really nice and
hot
these are
sirloin steaks sear it in the pan with
all that fat on i'll add flavor
salt and pepper
couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan
nice and hot
hold up the steak
and lay it in always lay away
give the pan a
little shake and it stops the steak from
sticking we're looking for color and if
it sticks it's gonna burn
[Music]
while the steaks are cooking i can get
on with my super quick marinade
now
two tablespoons of
misood paste that's a fermented soybean
that gives a really nice sort of rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar
a couple of tablespoons rice wine that
gives it a really nice vinegary kick a
couple of tablespoons of olive oil
salt and pepper
i'm looking for a nice sort of thick
rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
sort the pan
and to give the steaks a little base all
we're doing every time is just adding
more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really melt all
that fat down
off of the gas
take them out
just take your knife
see all that fat there just slice that
off
i don't want any of that
now
in
to the marinade
[Music]
beautiful
tacos are one of mexico's most popular
street foods they've been made from beef
pork chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now i want something sort of pickly
cabbage
these are
chinese cabbages slice it in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
we're going to slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
you think of cabbage here and you think
of sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but at a taco you want freshness
a little season chili flakes
they sort of discreetly
give it a little bit of heat
a little touch
of rice wine vinegar
if you haven't got that fresh lemon
juice
a small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix
now i need something to sort of bring it
together we take some wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
i'm gonna mix that
with a couple of tablespoons of
mayonnaise and give that a really good
mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them
actually place it
on
the gas ring
use some tongs
so as not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan
from there
i'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin
literally 30 seconds
as it cools down
the great thing about serving tacos is
people can fill them themselves just the
way they want them cabbage
just squeeze out wet marinade
a nice rustic little mountain
mayonnaise
on
wait you see
how soft
and delicious and almost sort of
melting in the mouth texture we've got
on this amazing sirloin
look at that really nice
sear around the outside
it's just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my crispy shell
back of the spoon with the wasabi
mayonnaise
inside taco
and just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my taco three or four
slices
touch more
on my spicy
layer
and that is how i'd make
the perfect taco
[Music]
my flavor packed lamb with fried bread
whether i'm cooking high-end dishes or
rustic dishes trust me it all has to be
impressive so this lamb dish proves that
you don't have to spend a fortune to
create delicious food
first off put the pan on
this is a lamb steak and it's cut just
above the leg just
here cause you can see that delicious
bone running through the center and
that's full of marrow so that just gives
the lamb a nice added sweet flavor just
take your knife cut through each end
this stops the
lamb steak from buckling so therefore it
cooks
evenly and colors beautifully salt
and pepper
lamb needs quite a lot of help with the
pepper so
be quite generous with the pepper
and just pat that down
the pan's just under smoke on the
outside now put the oil in get that pan
really nice and hot because this is a
cheap cut so
i'm depending on the color of the lamb
steak to really sort of impart a lot of
flavor
that's the noise you want to hear you
can't hear that noise don't drop a steak
in
put a little bit of garlic in there not
chopped garlic just whole cloves the
garlic lightly crushed
don't even waste time peeling them in
tongs lift up
that bit of fat around the back
that's the top of the leg
tilt the pan and let all that fat render
rendering is a chef's term that means
melting the fat it works brilliantly
when you're cooking a rib eye as well
turn it over
that color there beautiful
now it looks like an expensive cut and
we've got that nice even sear
all over
as it's cooking just tilt the pan
and base
and basting the lamb steak just means
you're sort of adding all that nice
scented
garlic olive oil back into the lamb
useful
now take the lamb out and let the lamb
rest
[Music]
now
for the perfect rustic crouton so this
bread's quite firm a couple of days old
just slice it straight down the center
dice it up
put it into a bowl
season it beautifully
[Music]
from there i'm gonna add some milk
sounds strange adding milk to crouton
but it just gives it that nice rich
creamy texture
and just let that milk sort of absorb
into the bread while that's soaking i'm
gonna make the dressing go back to that
initial garlic that was in the pan
look at that beautiful into the pest and
water anchovies
anchovies go brilliantly well with lamb
i want that nice salty vinegary flavor
and a bit of kick some capers
the little baby cats very sweet
now
just pound that to a nice paste
that smells incredible next some dijon
mustard a nice teaspoon and a half in a
little bit of red wine vinegar two
tablespoons and then our extra virgin
olive oil
now
it's got that heat in there i've got a
nice roasted garlic they're all hearty
chunky vinaigrette that sort of seeps
into that lamb
some fresh parsley
crunch up the parsley
delicious flavour parsley in
nice
now get your pan hot for the croutons
olive oil in the pan
grab the croutons and squeeze all that
excess milk out not too hard i don't
want them dry
and in
and then just fry them
and the milk inside these croutons
give it a nice spongy creamy delicious
flavor
that's the color i want nice
now take them out and lightly drain them
a little bit of kitchen roll onto the
board out
[Music]
it's a plateman just take it's amazing
vinaigrette
and spread it
get those croutons
listen to them
like little boulders hitting the play
the lamb
sit that on
next one
on
the rest of the croutons
on
now use all those little bits
and my chef in paris would kill me right
now if you saw me using those because
they're the ugly scraps that customers
should never see but but they're the
best bits
croutons on and then just
drop that sauce on all those little bits
of the lamb
and there that is a perfect way
of taking a cheap cut
is the premier league of dishes